they're still mad use it but but they're
quieter about it they're just quieter
now why are they quieter no who knows
maybe they made they got laryngitis
and their heart is in a much better oh
their hearts it's in a better place
everybody in the administration has a
heart of gold the media
as always they have one agenda and that
is to push whatever the democratic party
wants this headline from the new york
times is just
this is a stellar headline from the new
york times really full credit to the new
york times four points
here is the headline democrats once
outraged
take a quieter approach to migrant
children yeah that's a real headline
from the new york times
so you may have been wondering you
american citizen why it was that aoc was
going down to the border
and putting on a spontaneous white
outfit and standing spontaneously in
front of a chain-link fence
spontaneously
in front of a giant empty plaza
spontaneously in front of a
child holding facility and why a
photographer was spontaneously there
taking spontaneous pictures of aoc
spontaneously crying spontaneously while
looking spontaneously into camera
you may have been wondering why she was
doing that but she's got
nothing to say like she's not down at
the border right now and there's a
multiple
of the number of children being held in
detention facilities by the biden
administration amidst a coveted pandemic
that is still hitting
all the people who are migrating over
the border you may have wondered well
the
new york times has your answer they're
just taking a quieter approach you see
they're still mad but they're quieter
about it they're just quieter
now why are they quieter who knows who
knows could be
maybe they made they got linear and
tried us you never know
maybe it's just that their hands were
paralyzed they couldn't type or
something but you just don't know but
they're quieter
according to eileen sullivan at the new
york times house democrats who led an
angry charge against the trump
administration's treatment of migrant
children
have taken a much quieter tax since
concerns began emerging about conditions
at some of the emergency shelters set up
by the biden administration to deal with
minors at the southern border
where once only twitter assaults and
dressings down at house hearings would
suffice
democratic lawmakers are voicing worries
privately to administration officials
and the small staff
at dhhs which oversees the care if
problems persist the lawmakers say
they call again democrats say the
contrast is for good reason
former president donald j trump's
immigration policies were deliberately
cruel
devised as a deterrent to would-be
migrants while the biden administration
is trying hard to deal with a bad hand
oh is that why oh it's because you like
the people in the white house i mean we
can boil that one down right that's what
they mean
we like the people in the white house
therefore they're good people we don't
have to yell at them we just address it
we do a little back massage and maybe
we try and give joe a can of insure and
maybe he'll do what we want by the way
number of migrant children has not
decreased since joe biden took office
that was in january
it is now nearly the end of may
according to joaquin castro democrat of
texas the difference
is you have an administration who wants
to solve a lot of these challenges and
their heart
is in a much oh their hearts it's in a
better place it's like in a jar on the
shelf their heart is in a better place
representative veronica escobar democrat
of texas said she has so far been
impressed with the administration
officials working on the issue
they have a solid vision and a heart of
gold their with a heart of gold
and they seem to want to do the right
thing which is different from what i
experienced during the trump
administration said escobar during the
trump administration was all excuses or
sorry this is the way it is oh so
oh i see i see what's happening here
so now they just went quiet but the good
you know what they went quiet for a
reason it's because democrats have a
heart of gold
by the way what is the biden
administration actually doing they're
incentivizing massive illegal
immigration across the border today
washington post at the detention centers
in county jails that the trump
administration once filled with
immigrants facing deportations
thousands of beds are now empty the
immigration and customs enforcement
officers that president donald trump
lavished with praise have far less to do
on the streets of the u.s these days
under the new biden administration rules
curtailing immigration enforcement
ice carried out fewer than 3 000
deportations last month the lowest
levels on record
the agencies 6 000 officers currently
average one arrest
every two months ice under president
biden is an agency on probation
the new administration has rejected
calls from some democrats to eliminate
the agency but biden has placed ice
deportation officers on a leash so tight
some say their work is being
functionally abolished immigration
advocacy groups and lawyers who wield
significant influence in the biden white
house
are pushing to eliminate more detention
facilities and reduce deportations even
further despite a 20-year high in legal
border crossings
so you know why democrats aren't worried
about all these children being held in
migrant facilities because they're very
much in favor of the open border policy
being pursued by the biden
administration
once the administration says to ice you
cannot deport people who are crossing
the border illegally
they're de facto issuing a come on in
announcement free cupcakes
cross the border and then we're all
supposed to be surprised
when children swamp the border why
should we be surprised about that you
have fully incentivized this just like
defund the police cause his crime
we will not support anyone causes
illegal immigration
democrats know this and they don't care
they're happy about it
that's why they're quote-unquote quieter
because they like the broader agenda
they don't care that kids are being held
in inhumane conditions on the border
because the broader agenda which is to
get more illegal immigrants into the
country is something the democrats
support
as always real-time suffering means
nothing to democrats it's a long-term
utopian vision that means everything
to democrats the biden administration is
preparing to release its first
department of homeland security budget
request this week
immigrant advocates want deep cuts to
ice deep cuts ties in the middle
of a vast upswell in illegal immigration
cut the agency responsible for
deportations
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
announced plans last week to shut her
two ice detention centers
but he says he wants to reorient ice not
shrink it he said i really am focused on
it becoming a premier national security
and law enforcement agency
i really want to elevate all of the
other work ice does and also ensure that
its civil immigration work is well
focused
in the service of the national security
and public safety mission so what
exactly does that mean
under biden's new rules deportation
officers must seek written authorization
from senior level supervisors
to arrest anyone who is not a recent
border crosser
a national security threat or an
aggravated felon
okay so if you've committed a
misdemeanor you're fine
if you commit a felony but you're not
considered an aggravated felon you're
still fine
so long as you came here a little while
ago before placing a detainer on an
immigrant
in a jail or a prison so these are
people who have already been arrested
essentially asking another law
enforcement agency to hold that person
until ice can assume custody
officers must also seek approval from
one of the agency's most senior regional
directors so it used to be that
automatically if somebody was arrested
and they were an illegal immigrant
ice would put an automatic detainer
request in with local law enforcement to
say we can deport these people as
opposed to keeping them in american
jails
now biden wants you to have to go to
your supervisor to allow this which
effectively means a lot of people who
are
felons people who have committed crimes
in the united states will not be
deported
ice officials frustrated with the
changes describe a workplace environment
where officers spend time doing
paperwork
idling or working out more fearful of
facing reprimand for making an arrest
and not making one so basically they're
doing twice what they have done to the
cops and the predictable result
is more crime this is not a shock in any
way shape or form but don't worry things
are getting better guys according to the
new york times democrats are quiet
because
everybody in the administration has a
heart of gold so
much goldenheartedness going on by the
way a little bit of disparate treatment
of crime
you notice there's a big story out right
now about how a grand jury has convened
in new york with regard to president
trump
and how latisha james the attorney
general of the state of new york
came into office pledging to go after
trump she didn't say well crime he'd
committed but she was pledged to go
after
him acknowledge basically admitting that
there was political prosecution from the
very beginning
the media are over the moon about law
enforcement with regard to trump
when we don't even know what crimes he
supposedly has committed here but when
it comes to
actual people committing actual crimes
the answer is defund the police
make sure that kristen clarke who's a
radical with regards to the cops
is in charge of investigating the police
and ensuring civil rights
at the doj and defund ice
remember that time when this is supposed
to be a moderate administration yeah i
don't either
because it was never going to be a
moderate administration that was always
a lie that people
were just telling you end of story it
was all about that
and the media are playing the game man
whatever they can do to distract
from the failures of this administration
from the cri multiple
there are multiple crises there are
administration created there is a crime
crisis it is created by this
administration
and by the democrats and by the media
there is a racial polarization crisis in
the country fomented by the media
there's an illegal immigration crisis
fomented by the media
fomented by this administration but you
know it is the one-year anniversary of
george floyd so i guess we're not
supposed to talk
about any of that i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the ben shapiro show if
you did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button so you stay up to date with all
our future content